Give me...
The Stone.
Wow. You are seriously loyal piece of outerwear. Aren't you.
Yeah uh. Speaking of loyalty...
Hey, we haven't officially met.
Cool.
Will you stop doing that!
Can I? I need a...
Just need one strand of your hair.
Let me explain something my hair is not to
be meddled with.
Your father's here.
What's this? That's your brother Loki.
you're gonna need that.
Huh?
Oh you are good!
All right well I'll be off now um...
If it's all the same to you I'm gonna use
my feet to walk outside instead of
suddenly just being outside making me
feel rather queasy.
Sure.
I thank you for your help/
I sense a great change in
your future Thor.
A change you can neither
control nor avoid.
and you've chosen many
paths in your life but not only one
remains.
Destiny has dire plans for you my friend.
That's incredibly depressing.
Yeah I know sorry I didn't mean really by day
yeah okay well listen good luck with
that and don't forget your umbrella
can't you just magic it over to me?
Oh, I think we both know even this wizard can't do that.
See that's bad luck/
Guess that's what you were talking about.
It's exactly what I was talking about.
Good luck!
Nice guy.
Took you long enough.
I had to pick up
the key.
No one else needed a key!
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie!
This is going to be my new Avengers
infinity Saga deleted scene video for
Ironman becoming Doctor Strange Doctor
Strange becoming Iron Man and then Thor
versus Doctor Strange there's a whole
bunch of really cool Easter eggs in this
so we'll break it all down if you're new
to the channel we're still doing that
giant infinity saga box set giveaway of
all the blu-rays that's where these
deleted scenes came from so all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave all your theories on the video
about Doctor Strange too so we'll start
with the Iron Man Doctor Strange scene
just because I think that's a little bit
cooler then I'll talk about the Thor
scene so during the Iron Man Doctor
Strange scene what happened was is the
Iron Man and spider-man bored
evany Maas ship during Avengers infinity
war to save Doctor Strange the needles
evany Maul was using to torture Doctor
strange were going to be way more hardcore
and he would have been in way more pain
in the theatrical cut spider-man makes a
reference to James Cameron's aliens
asking Iron Man if he remembers the
ending of that movie where Ripley
battles the Queen into the airlock then
blaster out into the vacuum of space
Iron Man jokes with ebony mod that even
though he has crazy telekinetic powers
and magic off the charts the kid
spider-man has seen way more movies they
blast a hole in the hole venting ebony
maw out into space completing the joke
in the deleted version of this scene and
it's probably one of the coolest deleted
scenes from the Infinity Saga that
hasn't made it onto the blu-rays yet Doctor
strangers cloak of levitation joins Iron
Man and spider-man in their attempt to
save Doctor Strange but instead of Iron
Man just confronting evany maw head-on
like he does during the theatrical cut
he pulls in Iron Man 3 scene callback to
the time he saved Pepper Potts by
sending his Iron Man armor to cover her
during that big explosion
only this time during Avengers infinity
war he's since upgraded to his nano
armor so he sends his nano armor to
cover Doctor strange protecting him from
the needles so that's what it looks like
here thus this is what Doctor Strange
looks like in the full Iron Man armor
suit really cool side detail to when
he's wearing the Iron Man armor he's
called the iron mage
notice how the nano armor forms around
the eye of agamotto
was a visual callback to the way the
armor always forms around Iron Man's arc
reactors inside note there was actually
another new deleted scene from way
earlier in the timeline during Iron Man
2 where Ironman pulls the same move like
this putting his nano armor on Pepper
Potts so it just goes to show you that
Iron Man had nano armor as early as Iron
Man 2.
It doesn't mean anything to me you know
what means something?
Ohh! Aaah!
I hate this thing.
My nano ball?
I don't want to play with your ball.
So while Iron Man is saving Doctor
Strange he leaves himself vulnerable
because he doesn't have his nano armor
anymore so Doctor Strange his cloak of
levitation seeing that Iron Man has done
a Mossad
picks up the slack and covered Iron Man
helping him levitate down and protecting
him while they dealt with ebony maw
until iron man could get his nano armor
back we know that they filmed this scene
because we had behind the scenes footage
of Robert Downey jr. that they released
when they were promoting Avengers
infinity war this promo footage is from
way before infinity war ever came out in
theaters so we know that they actually
intended at one point to put this in the
movie in a lot of you longtime Marvel
comic book fans will remember that Iron
Man has become the sorcerer supreme in
the Marvel Universe a couple times in
the past there was a what-if story a
long time ago where he goes to the
ancient one to cure his quote-unquote
demon in a bottle all of his problems
and combines his science in tech with
his newly learned magical abilities to
become something more akin to a Doctor
Doom version of Doctor Strange one of
the really cool things about Doctor Doom
is that he's one of the few people in
Marvel Comics that is both a man of
science and magic there aren't that many
of them so that's why he's so useful in
big stories you could put him in an Iron
Man story you could put him in a Doctor
strange story more recently during the
Marvel legacy comic book series we saw a
distant future version of Iron Man that
had become enlightened enough to take
the mantle of sorcerer supreme from
Doctor Strange but that's sort of an
alternate future that may or may not
come to pass my early guesses they got
rid of this Avengers infinity saga scene
because they wanted to keep the movie
shorter and save the Iron Man Doctor
Strange twist for a more multiverse
movie down the road think Avengers
secret Wars are even possibly Doctor
Strange two multi
madness is just the Kevin Feige revealed
that we would be seeing alternate
versions of characters that we already
know during Doctor strange to multiverse of
madness which just implies that they'll
be viewing the multiverse so you get
brief flashes of alternate versions of
the characters the Thor versus Doctor
Strange scene is just a little more
comedic it's just a bigger version of
what we saw during the actual movies you
also noticed that Doctor strange is still
wearing his yellow gloves that's
actually a Taika Waititi touch because
tyga shot these scenes with Thor and
Doctor Strange when they were still
filming the Doctor Strange movie way
back in 2015-2016 there's an alternate
version of Doctor Strange showing up
Loki with his more powerful magic like
Loki just has this crazy vendetta
against Doctor strange but because this
version of Loki is the one that died
during infinity war I don't know if
we'll see another Loki versus Doctor
Strange fight because it had to be the
alternate version of Loki that has never
met Doctor Strange hopefully they'll do
something brief with that during Thor
for love and thunder
I think the cooler moment of this Thor
versus Doctor Strange scene though as
funny as it is is when he's able to read
Thor's future just by touching him so as
sort of them tipping their hand to the
big twist that they used during Avengers
infinity war where Doctor Strange uses
the time stone to see the millions of
alternate futures looking for one where
they can beat Thanos except when he's
reading Thor's future he's not using the
time stone as we can see but none of the
special effects were added during this
that's why you're able to see the
special string that they used to do that
twist with the Umbrella version of
Thor's hammer where he calls it to
himself but then it opens up see there's
this bad luck everyone let me know in
the comments though if they ever do
Doctor Strange becoming Iron Man Iron
Man becoming Doctor Strange when do you
think that we're going to see that do
you feel like they're going to wait till
Avengers secret wars which might not be
for another 10 years hopefully they
don't wait that long before doing Secret
Wars we'll be getting a venom 2 trailer
really soon another Wandavision trailer
in a new Falcon in Winter Soldier
trailer so office I'll do videos for all
that stuff when it comes but leave your
requests in the comments below and
everyone click here for all my other
Avengers infinity saga deleted scenes in
Easter eggs and click here for that
really big Thor for love and thunder
Christian Bale announcement thank you so
much for watching everyone stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight!